hi I'm Brent hi I'm Jason and today
we're gonna be drawing Looney Tunes
characters from memory our brain that's
a big universe I feel like the human
characters are gonna be hard if there's
human characters Looney Tunes are hard
yeah I don't think I've ever drawn any
lead since I probably through Bugs Bunny
as a child oh boy well let's get into it
his name is Marvin the Martian Sammy Sam
no oh no wait Oh turns have tabled so I
have an advantage for once you're gonna
kill me today yes so he's got massive
cheeks big buck teeth and then the big
eye okay wait a minute maybe I can draw
him oh my god I'm great
he's adorable I love aliens I love that
you could only really see his eyes his
voice is fantastic his voice is the best
so here's the thing Jackie since you
don't know feel free to ask me questions
and I will answer truthfully fielding
I'm gonna be nice to you
Susie oh so many say so he's the little
cowboy with the big hat and the big
mustache I have all these like big fake
cloudy memories let me put it in your
terms
he has chibi construction big head small
body
he's got more human construction than
most cartoon characters like his head is
not ginormous compared to the rest of
his body his ears are like long yeah
he's got long ears does he have like a
little like fuzzy thing on his butt yeah
like a tail it's funny how as soon as
you start drawing this you're like I'm
gonna fail but then you start you're
like you know I can remember
surprisingly well that is some people's
experience he has a big beard right so
he has a big red mustache
she's mouth ever and his nose you do see
his nose I think it's just that
separation of like the beard and the
mustache creates his mouth I mean he's a
cowboy John's a cowboy
[Music]
seriously I mean he has like a cowboy
hat
Tiffany wear like a little green skirt
he wears a little spirit very Spartan
yeah it's very Spartan so he has a big
hat bigger than his mustache yes it's
like a comically large hat this drawing
is getting even more confusing than I
started I don't remember if he also has
big bushy eyebrows too I'm gonna try the
big eyebrows yeah if they work I'm just
gonna do what you're doing cuz I don't
like being left out I'm gonna now he
looks mad so I think that you're
accurate coulisse of colors like he's
only like black green and red and wiry
wears the red shoes and then right his
helmets red it has red on it
it's like a Spartan helmet it's got like
if Kyra says that's what's happening in
Marvin's
bod that's what's happening she has like
attitude right oh yeah I don't know if
I'm getting the attitude right he's
always holding a carrot maybe it's out
of the side of his mouth hold anything
in mine he's holding on her to look like
himself
he's usually holding two large guns oh I
don't know how to draw guns good for you
thank you I'm gonna give him a cup a cup
of coffee that's why he's so angry
yeah he's caffeinated all the time in
his other hand it's gonna hold a cat you
said there was a red thing on here so
I'm gonna put a red thing on here oh he
put some hatred he feels like maybe he
doesn't sure do you remember him with a
shirt like a little black body and then
that green skirt does he have a shoulder
heads
I don't remember shoulder pads yo he's
got gloves right he has definitely got
gloves I don't know if he has a crotch
her knees but I gave him a crotch
he has a white chest right I don't think
so I gave him a belt I'm pretty sure he
has a belt like a big belt buckle does
he wear a collared shirt well no yes
he wears a vest
oh he probably has those cowboy spinning
Spurs first we have whiskers I think he
does good I feel like those would be so
annoying to draw if you're animating
them maybe he does well it looks weird
I'm taking away his whiskers help me out
with the colors I have no idea what it's
alright his moustache and beard is like
a reddish brown his hat I want to say is
a tan guys got that taste of hats I'm
done
there is Wow okay thanks Brent like
doing a new looks funny if I don't think
this is any more accurate the inside of
his ears are pink right of wanna see
could really pull this one out Jason
maybe you got this a night out I'm gonna
make his belt gold cuz he's a cowboy and
was feeling that's correct I don't know
what color to make it shirt
neither do I I'm gonna go with like an
orange okay then I'm gonna go with the
opposite of that
green green ooh that looks wrong that
one goes very wrong
I'm just gonna go with white now he
looks like an office worker okay I used
a white collar cowboy yeah I just
realize I didn't give him arms there we
go now he's gone
and then he's got a little sneaker shoes
I think this is as good as it's gonna
get I think I did okay I think I got the
spirit of him I think a lot of the
details I got wrong you know what they
say wrong and strong strong and wrong oh
okay yeah yeah I feel like you should
have made the mustache bigger I feel
like my mustache your mustache is very
large I think we're right that he didn't
have a shirt I think that's accurate
I love this rabbit on the right he is
the man
[Music]
you got his skirt more accurate than I
did oh you got hit his arm his hands
right completely oh you are really close
I remembered his beard be I mean his
moustache being way bigger and his mouth
floats in his mustache yeah that's weird
yeah whatever I just didn't draw the
carrot practicing this one I just feel
so good I his feet are iconic to me we
both were on the same wavelength of like
the brush thing on his head but we
weren't quite it was literally a brush
and all that talk we had about him not
having a shirt look at him he's in a
well I think you did an amazing job
didn't you I think you do the others
yours is ridiculously huge well you know
what you win some you lose some you know
and as you taught me before sometimes it
be like that
[Music]